les migrations 2è partie typologie des
migration cours de formation
géographique et sociale 5e
année la référence bibliographique
utilisée pour cet exposé le dictionnaire
de géographie aux éditions
Hatier il faut tout d'abord distinguer
les migrations internes des migrations
externes les migrations internes sont
les déplacement au sein d'un même État
au sein de frontières elles sont donc
limitées dans l'espace il s'agit
principalement de migration de voisinage
à titre d'exemple l'exode rural est une
migration interne les front pionniers ou
le déplacement des retraités qui
choisissent des lieux plus propices à
leur fin de vie sont des migrations
internes les migrations externes sont
généralement lointaines il y a un ou
plusieurs franchissements de frontière
il y a également parfois le
franchissement de certains
océans
évidemment les migrations externes sont
celles qui donnent naissance à
l'émigration ou à
l'immigration notons aussi que les
seules migrations internationales qui
soi de proximité sont le passage des
travailleurs frontaliers qui
franchissent la frontière chaque jour
pour aller travailler dans un pays
voisin précisons maintenant quelques
éléments démographiques importants
l'émigration c'est le fait de son pays
l'immigration c'est le fait d'entrer
dans un autre pays que le sien la
migration totale représente la somme des
départs et des arrivé pour un même
endroit la migration nette ou le solde
migratoire quant à lui c'est la
différence des arrivées et des départs
c'est-à-dire que le nombre de personnes
qui sont entrées moins le nombre de
personnes qui sont parties représente
mon solde migratoire si j'ai plus de
départ j'aurais un solde migratoire
négatif une immigration nette si j'ai
plus d'arrivé j'aurais un solde
migratoire positif une immigration nette
rappelons que le solde naturel
c'est-à-dire la différence entre le
nombre de naissance et le nombre desesss
plus le solde migratoire les arrivées et
les
départs forment ensemble l'accroissement
naturel de la population d'une région ou
d'un
pays
de manière intuitive on pourrait penser
qu'en Belgique le solde migratoire a
toujours été positif ce n'est pas le cas
on voit que ici aux périodes d'après-
guuerre il y a plus eu d'émigration que
d'immigration voyez que c'est un
phénomène relativement récurrent qui
s'installe dans la durée dans les années
80 évidemment depuis 1988 plus ou moins
on voit que le sold de migratoire est
positif et qui depuis peu il y a un
décrochage entre les deux
CS ce constat est corroboré par le
tableau statistique 6 juin vous voyez
que depuis 2004 le solde migratoire est
positif j'ai obtenu ce solde migratoire
évidemment en
soustrayant les immigrations les
émigrations pardon des desésimmigrations
et j'obtiens ainsi mon solde migratoire
vous voyez bien ici
que 164 52 Mo
100275 j'obtiens bien un solde
migratoire positif de
63877 à ce stade de l'exposé il est
important de préciser deux terme que
l'on retrouve souvent lorsque l'on parle
de migration le terme étranger est
totalement différent et ne recouvre pas
la même réalité que celui d'immigrer un
étranger c'est quelqu'un qui a la
nationalité diff différente du pays dans
lequel il vit même s'il est né dans ce
pays-là on peut imaginer que quelqu'un a
la nationalité italienne bien qu'il soit
né en Belgique et comme il réside en
Belgique il est considéré comme étranger
un immigré c'est quelqu'un qui est né
dans un pays différent du pays dans
lequel il vit même si un certain moment
il y a eu la naturalisation qui lui a
permis d'obtenir la nationalité
belge un Américain qui viendrait vivre
en Belgique et qui décide après 15 ans
de devenir belge serait toujours
considéré comme un immigré mais non pas
comme un
étranger pour établir une typologie
claire et nette des migrations on peut
se poser simplement quel est l'objet de
cette migration pourquoi Migron il y a
tout d'abord des migrations écologiques
elles sont les plus anciennes au
Néolithique beaucoup d'hommes ont
chercha à se déplacer pour trouver des
milieux plus propices à la vie
donc ces migrations sont très anciennes
et il s'agit en fait d'une adaptation
aux évolutions du milieu naturel qui
devient à ce moment-là trop exigeant
trop difficile pour la vie humaine à
côté de ces migrations écologiques nous
retrouvons les migrations forcées il y a
les différents types de diaspora ou de
déportation on peut penser évidemment à
la déportation des Juifs par les nazis
lors de la Seconde Guerre mondiale il y
a également les exils qui est la fuite
d'un pays où la vie n'est plus car on
est menacé de mort pour des idées pour
la pratique d'une
religion pour différentes raisons enfin
à côté de ces migrations qui sont des
migrations non volontaires nous avons
les migrations volontaires tout d'abord
des colonisations on peut penser
évidemment aux populations européennes
qui ont migré massivement vers les
États-Unis au 19e siècle il y a aussi
les rués quand on va découvrir par
exemple des gisements importants dans
certains états où on va permettre
l'acquisition de certaines terres des
individus vont décider à ce moment-là
d'aller vers ces régions où ils espèrent
avoir des conditions de vie meilleures
on pense bien sûr à la ruée vers l'or
aux États-Unis également 19e siècle on a
tous les mouvements qu'on pourrait
appeler armdrain ou braandrain qui
s'agit en fait d'un mouvement de
population économique dans le armrain ce
sont des individus qui vont on cherché à
proposer leur force de travail dans des
économies qui se portent mieux le
braandrain c'est tout simplement la
fuite des
cerveaux par exemple on constate que les
pays africains connaissent une un
certain brand drain puisque leurs élites
les personnes qui ont un diplôme
universitaire qui ont le plus de
compétences vont venir soit en Europe
soit aux États-Unis voir en Asie enfin
nous avons les migrations d'agrément qui
est simplement le fait de vouloir partir
pour changer de vie sans en être forcé
et juste pour améliorer le
quotidien un lien peut-être ici fait
entre le phénomène de migration et la
transition démographique que nous avons
étudié au premier semestre pour rappel
la transition démographique c'est
l'évolution de la population d'un pays
et en tout cas de des dynamiques qui
pèsent sur elle dans un premier s nous
allons constater que le taux de
mortalité va baisser voyez ici c'est la
première phase de la transition
démographique pour se stabiliser
ensuite le taux de natalité ne diminue
pas tout de suite mais vu que l'on meurt
moins il n'est plus nécessaire de faire
15 enfants pour se reproduire alors il y
a une diminution des natalités qui se
stabilisent ensuite aussi en le décalage
entre ces deux baisses vont faire
apparaître un pic ici qui correspond à
l'accroissement naturel c'est-à-dire
qu'il y aura nettement plus de naissance
que de décès et donc la population va
augmenter avant de se stabiliser puisque
les deux courpes se stabiliseront dans
la 4è phase où la transition est
achevée l'Américain willbur zensky va
établir un parallèle entre la transition
démographique et la transition
migratoire il va remarquer que lorsque
la transition démographique
commence les populations vont être
soumises à un exode rural important à
des migrations pionnières et des
migrations
internationales tandis que que lorsque
la transition démographique sera en
placee de se terminer plutôt ici quand
les deux courbes se rejoignent et se
stabilise les sociétés connaîtront la
fin de l'exode rural bien que les
migration pionnière et les migration
internationaleue on verra également
l'apparition de migration interurbaine
c'est-à-dire que les populations vont
migrer des centres urbains vers les
périphéries c'est ce que nos sociétés
ont connu depuis les années 50 et ce que
la Chine par exemple connaît
actuellement l'exposé touche ici à sa
fin avant de nous quitter n'oubliez pas
le quiz sur scogi notez les questions et
les les approfondissements que vous
aimeriez apporter au prochain cours et
je vous dis à bientôt